uh good morning I would like to open up
um Capital project overview committee uh
time being 9:03 uh we have a couple
members that are in transit they're
going to be just a couple minutes so uh
why don't we recess till uh 9:15 and
then we will uh continue with our
you
uh good morning um I want to open up out
of recess a capital project overview
committee agenda um we are going to hold
on the minutes and some other official
business hoping one more member
joins but I would like to start with old
business and I would ask Mr Shay to uh
brief the committee on what you have
yeah good morning for the record crishet
LBA um before you today you have a
number of pieces of paper related to the
quarterly report that's performed um by
administrative services on all the
capital
projects so I gave you it's um titled
capap
23021 it's got a folded page on
it that was the report that was in your
packet last
meeting and just in way of description
of the report the folded pages so it
looks like an Excel
spreadsheet that's the old quarterly
report where you would have all your
capital budget projects listed so
anything that was in House Bill 25 or in
a legislative special that was a capital
appropriation would have been listed in
that portion of the court of the
report um during this last session law
was changed to expand it from the
capital budget to all capital projects
so if you go beyond the spreadsheet
there's a an eight pages of agency
listing of projects including arpa
related projects uh self-funded types of
projects where they have restricted
revenue and then when you so that's all
the other agencies and it's only eight
pages and then you get beyond that and
there's the dot
report um and for the quarterly report
that was done do put together at the
time what um they had quickly available
today they present you an alternative to
that report because the number of
projects um that they do manage that
they consider capital is significant um
and it would require a little bit more
um effort and and work on their part to
get things done in a timely fashion and
they're here today to kind of discuss
their alter alternative report to you
and what they could provide the
committee for the uh future quarterly
reports
okay Senator thank you for
joining no no apologies necessary from
you
sir
settled
that's what I said to that's what got me
up early and then Karen said I wouldn't
have come if we we didn't have this
relationship
so the um I'll turn to the um to the
clerk and why don't we uh I think we're
under a quorum why don't we do a roll
call we'll open up
officially representative Maki present
here
here and nson Wilder gone Senator inis
yes sir Senator
delandro we're good thank
you we have um minutes from December 15
I'd like to um ask if anyone has any
omissions
Corrections on those minutes and if not
I'd be happy to accept a motion to for
those
minutes moved in seconded um any further
discussion on the minutes from December
15th seeing none if you're in favor of
the motion signified by saying I I those
opposed and one obain thank
you all right um we are now uh in a
quorum official meeting and with that Mr
Shay could I ask you to continue so so
what I just stated was all I had I think
you're ready to hear from the Department
of Transportation on um what they're
presenting today for a quarterly Report
with would like some feedback from the
members as to whether this meets the
needs and the requirements that is set
forth in this committee thank you
commissioner C do you want to bring come
this morning Mr chairman uh for the
record uh my name is Bill Cass
Commissioner of New Hampshire dot with
me is Danielle uh Shand our uh Director
of Finance um I appreciate the
opportunity to to talk to the committee
just to make sure the the biggest thing
I want to make sure that the reporting
that we provide is is is useful to to
you all um as um as uh Mr Shay had noted
we we have a substantial amount of of
projects and the change in reporting
requirements from just the capital
budget to all capital projects you know
raised a lot of questions in in our mind
um
everything everything that we end up
doing tends to be um Project based and
we have uh a lot of projects to soort to
say in our system that are whether
they're fully projects or programs but
tracking all of the FTA all of the FAA
in addition to our Highway and Bridge
projects um and all of kind of our um on
call type of um consultant uh design
contracts they're all tracked and
referenced in our system as as separate
projects so the initial report to be
responsive that that we gave to um and I
think is included with that comprised
about close to 600 individual lines and
individual um uh projects and uh myself
looking at it I questioned how useful it
was I I don't know if you all would find
that very very useful but um so mainly
my intent we just want to be um
responsive but we also want to make sure
that the information that we're
providing is is useful and what the uh
committee intended so um we have as I
said we have an awful lot of projects
through our Capital program a highway
and bridge program uh numbers of them in
various um
um phases of of completion whether
they're just beginning in Project
scoping whether they're in active design
and and development or whether they're
in construction or just finishing up
construction um also I'd also want to
just point out we do a lot of other um
reporting um and wanted to just uh
double check if some of that had could
have dual purposes so for for our
Highway and bridge program for our um
you know Capital um transportation
program um in addition to the 10-year
plan which we report on an update every
every two years the first four years of
the of the 10year plan become What's
called the the stip the State
Transportation Improvement plan um and
through Federal requirements and stuff
we we are uh reporting on that to a
broad bunch of of people the regional
planning commissions and the federal
agencies every every quarter on on on
that as well too um which contain mostly
the the the active projects and things
that are going on in the immediate uh
four
years um and that's that goes to a
public process of of approval and sign
off by the federal agencies and and well
too so it looks very similar to um to
the 10-year plan that you've probably
seen in the past and a listing of
projects but it is kept up um very um um
very frequently with quarterly
updates um with with all that said um
one of the things we'd like to suggest
and you have in front of you and and
Danielle and her team had put together
you know kind of a a subset from the 600
projects that we had um originally
presented to be responsive and and I
think you know we we feel
that this may be of more value to you
than than what we had provided um this
this is really uh what we would consider
if you ask our opinion these are really
our capital projects these are the
highway and Bridge projects it doesn't
contain all of the um FTA programs uh it
doesn't include like the FAA funding and
things like that which which go to
projects but they aren't projects that
that we as the do or as a state agency
um um manage or oversee we provide
funding uh towards those agencies uh for
their own projects and their own
programs we report and I mean we we
Monitor and track those um but reporting
on those I don't know if we would have
the most current and accurate
information and I'm and I'm not sure if
that's the type of information that the
committee is looking for so this report
doesn't include any of the federal train
Transit um programs or the FAA programs
this is um really all of our state
highway and Bridge type of
Transportation projects state funded
Turnpike funded federally funded um this
does not contain any of the um
municipally managed projects so these
this is a report of just do managed
projects um we do provide through
various programs funding to cities and
towns for for there um municipally
managed projects which again we uh track
and and and monitor but we're not the
active managers of that um so this
report um that you have in front of you
uh I I we we we would recommend this if
this meets your needs um we have this
the queries and stuff uh set up from
from some of those other reports that I
had mentioned and uh we can provide this
uh quartly uh and um but I just wanted
to make sure it was clear what it
contained and and and what it um what it
didn't contained and I should also say
we also did put a threshold on this
report that it's every everything over a
million dollars is that right yeah
so so that would be our suggestion I
gave you some of the background of why
we wanted to address the committee um
and if you have any questions of us
we're um happy to answer them
delandro please well thank you Mr
chairman bill this is really terrific
for for for me and I call I call you a
lot then I speak to to your staff a
lot projects you know where are
they how can we address them we never
have enough money right I mean that's
that's the bottom line we never have
enough money and as a result of that we
see projects but but we see projects
scheduled and and pushed down and and
and so forth but uh my hats off to you
for the job that do does you know given
given the constraints and I've been
looking at the numbers and the numbers
aren't favorable to us as we we that we
just don't look good the gas tax money
is not on target the registrations are
not on target the license renewals are
not on target I mean the kinds of places
where we got the money uh they're
diminishing and so where's the money
going to come
from that's
problem now what what we did with the
electric vehicles helps to some extent
all right to some extent but generally
speaking all of all of these projects
have a cost associated with them and
I've been on the case for exit 6 in
Manchester all right came up this
morning I was late I apologized another
goddamn accident another one this
morning there was there was another one
on Thursday morning when I came up car
across the road here's a woman with a
child uh getting getting out of getting
out of the car that that's a death trap
and we've been talking about that as
long as I've been here that's that's I
know there's a cost associated with it
it's a toll road it's the F return Pike
well if you don't increase the tolls
there's never going to be enough money
to fix
it I'm I'm very concerned about these
projects falling falling
behind I think what we do we do well and
and I compliment us doing well but we we
have a tough time hiring people we have
a tough time youve been on the god rails
forever you know I know and we're
replacing God rails all the time people
are driving
crazy uh they're smashing them up and so
and I don't want to go on a DI it's it's
great information but the implementation
is really the issue and as we sit around
this this table we're thinking about
safety security for for the roads
bridges in our in our system we did we
did give the municipalities some money
in this this budget I was able to get 10
million and so forth but look at the
roads are Fallen apart they are they are
falling apart so uh the report's great
but the bottom line is when are we going
to have enough resources to do these
jobs and and we have resp responsible
for that we keep reducing our ability to
to to have resources and if we if we
keep doing that then we have nobody to
blame but but ourselves but I I like I
think the report's great it's great
information and uh you know data
everybody wants a lot of data now so but
this takes time and effort to put
together it's a cumbersome task to to do
all of this and to upgrade upgrade all
of this and if you can't fill positions
that means people are doing more than
than they have to do they're taking on
other responsibilities so I PL you for
that uh long way of saying I think
everything
is here but I my my fear is for the
future I I really am fearful of the of
the future and uh we we're we're keeping
killing people in the highways they
they're driving too fast we're fixing
the guard rails but they keep breaking
them yeah and I we got I think we have
some real we have good information but
we have to react to it in a positive
sense that's all thank you Mr thank you
Senator um
represent commissioner I like the uh the
format and the layout and it's certainly
far more easy to read through than the
um one in the packet my only Proviso is
if you
consider to stay more with within the
spirit of the legislation passed have we
okay Chris to representative Eaton's
point that this committee um in this
fall had adopted the million dooll
threshold so that would be if you want
to change the threshold it would be for
all agencies not just for the do
necessarily um but the million dollar
threshold for your information from Mr
meet was suggested by by the committee
as a way to um kind of limit the number
and types of projects that might be
captured because there's a lot of
projects that are a few hundred, that
maybe this committee doesn't necessarily
need to look at um on a regular basis
you're more interested in those larger
larger projects prior to my joining and
I go with that Spirit thanks for the
update yep thank you representative
thank you Mr Shay representative please
yeah thank you um thanks very much for
doing this this is one of these things
where we when we originally moved from
the capital budget oversight committee
to the capital project oversight
committee I don't think we were thinking
of the many many do uh projects that
would be affected by the change in the
reporting requirements so clearly you
have a lot of projects that fell within
the million dollars um I I think this is
a great way of formatting it um my only
question to you would be is this causing
you another huge amount of time time to
prepare this report
or we hate for you to do a lot of uh I
mean things were percolating along
anyway so I was just curious um so we
found a way to automate this um process
there is still it's not 100% automated
but the amount of time is far less than
the original Pro product that we had
provided so we believe that we can do
this on a quarterly
basis
follow please I mean is it useful for
you in some way to see the information
compiled in this way I'm just curious uh
I would say um it's it's it's it's it's
another review but um quite frankly um
this would be a report just just for the
capital budget uh Capital project
oversight committee um the other reports
that that I mentioned are are much more
uh scrutinized and we work with the stip
which we which everybody um deal deals
with in uh you know the regional
planning commissions and and the
approval process and you know that that
reporting in that that process is much
more
um our level of focus um you know part
of that is federal requirements we
cannot we cannot work on a project we
cannot spend money on a certain phase of
a project unless unless it is reflected
in in the step so we have a lot of um
time and effort and and focus and
scrutiny on on that report um we also
provide to the industry a three-year
look ahead of of construction
projects um it's called our advertising
schedule we meet monthly to review the
um advertising schedule and that's the
list of projects that uh that we're
anticipating going out to Construction
in the next um two to three years um
that's another publicly available report
we publish it every every month to the
uh
to the industry so they see and know
what's what's coming so that's a kind of
a long answer to you know we're more
focused on some of those other other
other reports for the reasons i' I've
noted this is all the same information
it's it's it's um reformatted a a little
bit um to hopefully make it easier and
uh more trackable but
um okay so it's and and as Danielle said
we we have put some time into the the
queries and the reporting from from our
uh uh project information system that
that uh that we feel it isn't terribly
burdensome to report to to um um issu
this report quarterly along with some
some of the other ones it's all the same
database and it's we've got the the
format and the um uh stuff set up to
produce this report relatively
straightforward
thank you Mr Shay did you have a comment
I just had a question if I might have
the commissioner um in terms of the
report I just want to make sure that the
Committees what's the number State
reference is that the um number that you
find in the 10-year plan yes yeah that
is a state project number and as I said
everything everything we do we start
with a assigning a project number and
that's how it's generally tracked
through our financial systems and so
forth yeah so further comment is this
this report
though it's coming to this committee may
be useful to like the Public Works
committee when you're thinking about the
10-year plan and and members are asking
about the status of a project it's kind
of the cliffnote version of the 10-year
plan to say the project and Alton this
number this is where it's at and when
you're asking questions of the
department might be a little bit more
focused um so I just wanted to point
that out to the committee members I
agree with that I think it could be
handy for you guys for like uh division
two US SC
you guys sorry I used to be part of you
guys you Public Works folks yes no I uh
I'm very appreciative of this report
really am I think it's a good thing are
there further questions of the
commissioner um Mr Shay would would we
need a motion to accept this new format
or just an understanding that I I I
would um like that just so that it's
clear that the committee does approve of
the new format there's no questions
going forward in case there's a a shake
up with committee members in the near
future for some reason I'll make that
motion okay motion made to accept the
format seconded
by em um any further
discussion if you're in favor of that
motion signify by saying I I motion
carries unanimously thank you both
please thank you so much for your time
no thank you we have the commissioner
okay
we will
um we will move on to our second item uh
director Mason would you mind bringing
forward good morning uh for the record
my name is uh Scott Mason executive
director of New Hampshire fishing game
um and I have brought uh chief of Inland
Fisher today Diane uh Timmons to speak
on our Hatchery project uh before we get
to that I would like to just take a few
minutes and give you a brief update on
our ohrv registration please uh project
that we've been working
on uh and and I do apologize I know some
of you were at I believe it was a fiscal
meeting where I reported on where we
were at um so to bring everybody up to
date um the company the the um vendor
that we use to do our licensing and our
registrations has been called S3 and
they have been bought out uh by a
company called the new company is now
called pay it
um the the mother company and I
apologize I don't have the name of the
mother company but when the two came
together they changed it to pay it um
they actually have um they don't have
experience in um fishing game license
sales but they do have a lot of EXP
experience in providing uh interactions
between constituents and States uh both
with um automobile registrations and and
other functions um where they're trying
to
um sell the product or the services
between the between citizens in the
state um as I originally when we
approach this project to begin with I
originally warned folks um right now
fishing game is going through a major U
upheaval in our computer systems this is
just one of the issues that we are
facing um because of that uh in this
year's budget we worked with doit and we
uh created um for the first time we're
going to have a doit lead position at
fishing game it's a new position it's a
part-time position we split this person
with a veterans hospital and today is
her first day on the job so um this
person will will be helpful to us and
help coordinate activities between our
folks that work with our registrations
as well as our doit staff so this is a
step forward on this project and all the
other projects right now pay is um
steadily working on updating our license
uh
software um I believe in 2012 the
legislature passed um um a
law where we we join the um North
American
compact um so if you have your hunting
or fishing license suspended in any
state and now all 50 states belong so if
you have your hunting and fishing
license suspended in any of the 50
states uh you can't buy a license in a
different state if it's if there's a
similar charge in that
state um and we just we we joined the
compact in 2012 but we never actually
instituted the software to make that
happen so right now that's what uh pay's
working um spending the bulk of their
time on they will be working on this
they they are also working on this
project and when when that gets done
this project will become their main
focus on on the work we're doing you're
going to be seeing us in the very near
future uh we need to uh extend the
contract um with uh S3 pay it so that we
we will uh we had a 5-year renewable
contract and we're going to we're going
to plan on extending that contract
fairly shortly my folks are uh my staff
starting to work on that now is there
any questions from committee um I do and
then I'll be happy to take so um how how
many of your so you mentioned licensing
and that's fishing and hunting yeah uh
what else what else do they handle or do
we do so that's in our business office
um within within our business division
we have um
um two folks that are actively managing
you know the computer side of stuff um
and they you know we have an online
presence selling um licenses we have and
they also are responsible for all of the
um license sales at headquarters or at
the Regional Offices all of our license
sales now like if you go to a uh a gun
store to buy a hunting or fishing
license today that's actually an online
sale um it's not I'm sure you folks if
you've been buying hun hunting and
fishing licenses in New Hampshire you
remember the old pads and the books all
of that's gone uh you'll notice today
the salesperson will get on a computer
and and then they print out your license
for you so everything's an online we're
we're completely online presence even at
headquarters we're online now if you
were to go to headquarters to buy like a
lifetime license
that's still a manual practice that they
do and we have uh two people that are um
in the front office uh five days a week
selling thank you what what percentage
are just doing it online and not is
there any could you give me some idea
are you 70% of your business is people
are sitting at their home P you know
purchasing
licensing uh I do not have that figure
on top of my head I I do have a figure
this year because it's the first year we
did online deer registration
and we were over 50% with online deer
registration this year thank you so you
know year one we hit 50% so I'm guessing
we above that on on on hunting and
fishing licenses sounds good I just uh
my son made me aware of the fact that
the lifetime reg uh license possibility
for someone from birth to one year old
yes so we in my house with my twins are
scraping up money we're hoping to pull
that I told them we'd split it one in
one questions yes please
representative yeah I would suggest that
you talk to doit because I recently had
a presentation somewhere I don't know
where I was that the commissioner from
doit is trying to
standardize uh citizen interactions
using
salesforce.com yes okay so you're you're
aware of that yeah okay I just want to
make sure thank you further questions
the director
seeing none thank you could you continue
on another part to your presentation so
I'm G to have um uh Diane Timmons give
the presentation today one thing I will
say is is that um we cut the
presentation down to 15 minutes and and
um we were requested to do that for you
folks today uh so um we may have left
out a few details that like we presented
the other day to the uh GNC we did a
half an hour presentation with the
governor and Council
um we are going out
what for those of you that know me
realize keeping my mouth shut is not a
natural thing for me and one of the
issues with the Hatchery uh situation
was is we were we were being sued by
Seal you know we'd gone in to get a
permit EPA NEP permit down at the new
Durham Hatchery and and through that
process we ended up getting sued it's
been a long settlement case that is now
settled um we've gotten the final decree
uh while they they've issued the uh the
decree on that uh I'm sorry consent
decree um so now we're out talking and
um uh Diane and I have been before you
know the state Council trout unlimited
we did a zoom meeting with them um we
will be uh we made our we will be
speaking at the yif
um um yeah uh Heritage Foundation we've
offered to speak in front of them the
wildlife uh Federation will be speaking
before them we're going to be having two
public meetings one in conquered one in
Lancaster um I got there was a issue
with somebody out sick and I got called
up on a nine o'clock on a Saturday
morning at noon time I was presenting to
the gron fishing game club about the
Hatchery about our Hatchery uh stuff so
we are starting to get out and talk to
folks um we have made arrangements we'll
be speaking to the um house fishing game
committee and I've made a request to the
chairman of the Senate A&E um for us to
speak be you know before that committee
too thank
you okay hi so thank you for this did
Sor the two of us together are a bad mix
I have no problems talking for a long
period of time as well so I always get
the warning you know 15 minutes 15
minutes so
I will keep it toight um so thank you
for the opportunity to speak today uh
the Hatchery project is a very
passionate subject for me personally
because I have been working for the
state for almost 30 years and um have
done all sorts of things related
Fisheries so started in keen and worked
my way all up and now in this position
so um staff is very excited about this
opportunity and so thank you for letting
us speak about it today so why do we
care about the Hatchery modernization
project and we care because fishing is a
huge part of New Hampshire in the most
recent study done by norc uh in 2022 it
determined that anglers in New Hampshire
spent 3.5 million days fishing and they
contributed to the economy of New
Hampshire 1.4 billion dollars in 2022 so
angling is a huge deal and part of that
is stocking stocking will always be a
part of New Hampshire which leads us
into the Hatchery
situation so you can I'll turn as you
guys can turn as I turn um I'm not used
to doing this on paper I'll just refresh
that I'm used to a PowerPoint so just
bear with me if I Stumble a little bit
in between Pages um so we have six
facilities uh four of which are a 100
years old one is 75 years old and the
last one the youngest is over 50 years
old so a lot of of old facilities that
now are all in the historic possibility
realm and um we a lot of them have
failing infrastructure they have failing
raceways we have mended concrete to the
point where you try to mend it and it
crumbles continues to crumble we have
issues with buildings we have issues
with roofs windows and of course
Predator control and so um lots of
things going on at our facilities one of
the biggest things that powder mil for
example is we have major major issues
with predation because we just have
netting over those raceways and
unfortunately all sorts of predators can
get in and predators are a problem
because we feed fish you think there's a
certain amount in that pool and long and
short they get eaten you're still
feeding until you do the next sample and
all that food turns into waste so and
part of the issue as Scott had director
Mason had mentioned is that the um waste
water is an issue for us we got sued at
Powder Mill by clf part of that
Wastewater issue is that our phosphorus
levels are too high and so we um long
and short we having issues with that
feed with the predation and it's not
just poop it's actually the breakdown of
the food as well so being able to
control those Predators is really
important so it's not just a failing
infrastructure situation it's also um a
lack of control on the covers
so next slide um so what we're hoping to
do our proposed summary here is that um
two of our facilities two of our largest
facilities part of Mill and Berlin have
um issues with impaired water so as we
mentioned the downstream of mar meeting
the downstream of Powder Mill Hatchery
the mar meting River has three ponded
areas that have been deemed impaired by
Dees and impaired as a category that um
usually leads to elevated
cyanobacteria and other issues that um
our effluent is not helping of course
and so po Mill we did a year and a half
long feasibility study with HDR
engineering and in that feasibility
study it determined that powder Mill's
wastewater treatment was going to cost
67 million dollar so much much much
higher than our budgeted amount and so
um that was an issue and they also
couldn't guarantee our EPA permited
level of 12 parts per billion so it was
a no possibility option for us and so
then we were looking at an alternative
um so Berlin also has an impaired water
body York Pond and at Berlin it's in the
process of its EPA permit renewal it's
nip removal I mean sorry renewal and so
right now we're not sure where we're
going to be at Berlin and um so in
anticipation uh to be good faith we
actually moved some of our production
and changed how we do things there we
actually removed our brood stock and so
now our brood stock fish which is our
breeder fish so where we get our eggs
how it worked is in New Hampton we have
brown and brook trout eggs we have
breeders that breed and we take those
eggs on station within station
and then Berlin covered the North
Country for brook trout and so what we
did was take those breeders away we
actually stocked them out it was a nice
fall this year um but stocked them out
and then moved fish that were actually
discharging into York Pond move those
fish out of those raceways and put them
down where the Breeders were so right
now in good faith we took those fish so
there's no affluent going into York Pond
from our fish and so those raceways are
empty and then also you'll see here that
um we reduced the proposed poundage our
Productions by 10,000 and that was just
a a potential guess we're anticipating
that we're going to have a limit right
now we do not um but we're anticipating
that we're going to in the other parts
of the Hatchery so we were just again
just trying in good faith to see what we
could do so that's Berlin um again
unknown on What's happen happening uh
the other thing I failed to mention with
powder mill is that it's actually a year
ahead of arpa um the Gopher funding and
so in 2025 we have to remain compliant
with that and so what we've decided to
do since we can't afford the wastewater
treatment um is actually reduce our
production down to 30% and so that or
roughly 30% so that's the
30,000 so we can maintain that facility
open in the consent decree clf and EPA
have agreed to those conditions as well
so we don't really want to close it
either so um that's our opportunity at
this point in time um to kind of save
some time and um obviously under the
circumstances it's just not economically
feasible to move forward without a
guarantee of 12 parts per Vilan so at
30,000 pounds HDR in the feasibility
study determined that they think we can
meet that so um that's the issue with
part of Mill still but um which leads us
to New Hampton so New Hampton is our
centralized location M could I stop for
one second sure could the proposed
pounds what pounds of what fish fish
fish well that's what we thought but
before we you went on I thought I would
ask to make sure no thank you and please
do because I you know this is my brain
so if something seems weird definitely
feel free to ask okay thanks my world is
probably different from yours um yes no
thank you uh yes so pounds of fish
that's all species brck Browns rainbows
Etc that's our stocked out fish poundage
that we need to maintain to reach our
Targets in respective water bodies um so
New
Hampton centralized location um right
now justes is under the general permit
uh those permits just got renewed in
October so we don't have an issue of
having to renew anything um and it has
the capacity it has the space to be able
to have a facility constructed that can
produce 150,000 PBS and what we'd like
to do um as you can note here with the
math that we're still going to be short
even with this new facility but in
future phases we're constructing this
facility to be able to expand to up to
250,000 pounds which would of course put
us in a very good place as far as
production and um determining other
things going on at the other facilities
in future phases so um that and also we
would at that point um the reason we
couldn't go right into
250,000 is we would be looking at and
garnering permits and research for
release into the pem joasa river versus
the dickerman brook that it currently
goes into um and then the other
facilities Milford and Warren are kind
of on hold and twin we're hoping at some
point in a future phase um with
additional funding to move forward with
a broodstock program for our rainbow
trout right now we bring our rainbows in
from out of other states and it is not
cost effective it can be very uh
problematic we've had issues with
rainbows in the past huge Statewide
shortages because we get the secondary
eggs the timing of the eggs is different
we um have had issues with FedEx
shipping the eggs and so it's very
costly for us to do that and so having
our own brood would be excellent um
again an additional cost for future
phases but um and powder milk I mean I'm
sorry and um twin is an area that
actually has really good water quality
it has great alkalinities for rainbow
trout so New Hampton our golden child at
this point um this is our conceptual
design uh right now it's three
additional buildings we would demolish
what was there on site now and we would
have a hatchery building that would be
completely enclosed and um running on
New running on freshwater and then the
intermediate rearing and growout
buildings would be what are called Raz
systems so it's recirculating
aquaculture and but those two buildings
would actually be um the middle one is
sort of a pavilion style and then the
growout building will be covered with um
a fabric material and so that would help
us with of course the predation control
and it would also help us with um
outside source
uh contaminants that can happen so with
that um it enables us to control
bacteria and other things that we
currently don't have the capacity to do
right now um so next slide we'll talk
about Raz um so the Raz facility is much
much much more efficient it's exactly
what it says recirculating aquaculture
meaning that it uses 95% of the water
you can have different rad systems 75%
90% 95 what they're talking about for us
here is 95% recirculating and so it
basically is starts in your influent
building it then goes through a whole
bunch of filtration it allows us to have
much better control on a ton of ton of
issues so your predation is obviously
not an issue it's covered your um
bacteria that you have we can treat with
UV light uh so that's a whole system
that's Incorporated ated into this you
can manipulate your temperatures for
growth and you can control growth so if
you need it to be a little bit warmer
faster growth you can increase temps if
you need to slow things down you can do
that as well um but again all helping
with in a hatchery system it's really
important to have uniformity so a lot of
people think you know in the wild
there's a lot of different heterogeneity
but here in a hatchery we want it's much
easier to do things that are under the
same timeline and so that temperature
enables us to do that and so some other
things oxygen Etc you can increase your
production so as I said with the
development of this structure we're
building it at 150,000 pounds but it has
that capacity with increased oxygen and
higher so the next slide here's where
the money is right um so with this
particular project we're doing it a
little bit different we're doing a
construction manager at risk and versus
just your design bid build design bid
and then you get your whole process for
a manager Etc we're actually going to
tie that process together um it was
actually an opportunity that DPW
suggested and um in this particular case
it will work fantastically for us to
obviously meet the timelines that we
need to meet for gopher but it will also
enable us to have the design Engineers
working directly with that construction
manager and so they can work out details
of products that way we can get a much
better idea on what the actual value
will be what those costs are we can lock
those costs in so it'll be a lot more
efficient and we can also pre-order on
items that we know that we're going to
um need so that we can actually lock
those prices in get those items on hand
and get that money encumbered I'm
unfortunately I'm running really tight
here yep and leave leave a couple
moments for questions yep sure and so um
um that's really the basis of that it
just allows us to get that timeline in
and um and I think that was yep and then
the last slide is just the critical
dates that um we need to meet as far as
the project goes and where we'll be so
the key part for um you folks is that
the May
2024 timeline is is when we will get our
maximum bid from our maximum price from
the construction manager that is chosen
at the time and then the GNC approval
will occur in August and then um 100%
design and construction at the beginning
of 2025 and then completion in 2026
thank you I sincerely appreciate that
update of questions from the committee
thank you absolutely
you we haven't determined that yet right
we will have um in order it's not just
abil raise effici ability to get
minimum
end once the project built um there may
be some discussion on whether we
increase the number of fish we ra or
whether we close Main
thank
you m Shay do you have anything else
before setting a date for our next
meeting so um I'd like to propose so we
have for planning purposes uh April 5th
is our next meeting and we can adjust
that depending on what uh and it would
be nine o'clock again for Capital
project and um long range for 10 o'clock
we'll bring that up at the next meeting
all
right with that uh is there any any
questions of the
committee
Senator Mr cheber the costs of all of
these projects are these going to be
Capital expenditures that will occur in
the next capital
budget for hatcheries I I I believe
you're correct in your assumption we had
we had appropriate a certain amount you
speaking of the hatcheries yes
yes that's Mr chair yes the hatcheries
were provided 50 50 or 55 million of
arpa funds so that's part of the reason
for the time frame that she was talking
about as well as there was an
appropriation for Powder Mill of $4.6
million in the two Capital budgets ago
the most recent capital budget um
expanded the scope of that so they had
to apply those funds towards Powder Mill
and if there was anything left over they
could use it towards the rest of the
Statewide project so that you shouldn't
see too much going forward okay good
thank you thank you Chris thank you Mr
um further questions motion to adjourn
all those in favor signify by saying I I
thank
you thank you uh for
weathering to be here I really
appreciate it yeah we'll go slow this
time okay all right we will uh we will
capital